on May 10th 2012 film courage attended a
press roundtable interview with Andie
MacDowell and daughter rainy quali for
the film mighty fine written and
directed by Debbie Goodstein
this audio contains the full interview
from that press day for more information
on mighty fine which opens in theaters
Friday May 25th please visit mighty fine
- the movie.com it was great I think we
had a very professional relationship my
mom gave me a lot of space to figure
things out for myself and but she was
definitely there for me when I needed
any guidance as well I felt really took
me under his wing during the film and
sort of gave me a mass and showing the
ropes and just things that I wouldn't
know having just taken acting classes
but you just learned by doing it he was
very generous in that way well how long
did you have you been acting and when
did you decide to become an actress I
think I decided to become an actress
it was like five she kept telling me but
I thought it was just a kid talking I
didn't I didn't let her but she's been
dancing
that's our dancing when I was two and I
sing and both of my parents are very
creative so I've been involved in the
arts basically my whole life and I
studied acting for two years in New York
and I studied in London for a summer at
Rada and sort of just went right out of
school as I was finishing my acting
training I booked this movie so I got to
go straight into filming which is when
it flies do you give to ringing Andy
about success in Hollywood especially as
it relates
female because it's slightly different
for men than it is for women so what
advice do you give her um giving her all
kinds of it by I told her well one thing
I've told her but not you know I don't
want her to focus on it too much because
I you know you can't doubt yourself by
any means but I always try to never be
desperate and have enough another idea
like way back in the back of your head
if things don't pan out but yet you know
it's it's a very vulnerable place and
you you're gonna have as an actor you're
never secure most actors are insecure
because it's a very insecure business
and it's learning how to kind of roll
with the punches never tell you anything
too serious or personal you never know
what the judgment is it's not always
necessarily about the quality of the
work it could be just the way you look
another thing I have a tendency to be
shy and very reserved so she tells me to
be confident and believe in myself and I
learn and have to learn those skills
like these are great skills for her just
learning that you know do this it's all
it's all skills but you have to learn
how to you can't expect to miracle
I mean you know the funny thing is
there's a lot of confident people make
it because confidence when you exude
confidence you create confidence at
other people but you're someone can't be
be confident just by saying be confident
you know you have to pull that up from
somewhere has done you have to find it
to find your confidence and you know
it's easy easier said than done the one
I think one of the best things I've done
but as I to each audition is not so much
about securing a job because maybe if
the audition it's about creating an
energy within the person that you're
auditioning for that they will remember
they go wow
so you're all you know an audition it's
not so much about getting the job it's
about convincing the person that you
could even that this was your first
feature film how was your experience of
creating your character getting to her
headspace and relating to her and also
creating that that sisterly dynamic with
Janelle oh well before we started
filming and worked with an acting coach
for like two weeks in New York before I
went down to New Orleans and also having
come straight out of training I had you
know plenty of techniques to draw upon
to try to get into character and make it
real for myself and then as far as
creating a bond with Joe Donlon with the
rest of the family one of the first
things we did when we got to New Orleans
was Chaz took us all out to lunch and
try to get to know each other and then
from then on just spending time with
each other on and off set enjoy Devils
of sweetheart so it wasn't hard to feel
friendly with her at all and I have a
younger sister myself so just you know
drawing on that relationship you're the
the singing voice you have is amazing
thank you well I was surprised it hasn't
been publicized as much as
should be talk about that a little bit
where did you get the pipes I just love
to sing and my dad's musical and my mom
her mother was a piano player so she's
losing a area yeah she's good to go as
well so I don't know I guess growing up
I think my dad's family they were known
as the singing qualities cuz they all
sang I guess
so it's in the genes I suppose and I
just love singing so and you know I'd
like to ask you about learning how to do
the accent that you did mm-hmm and how
difficult that was it came across so
natural no thank you I worked with the
Sam squad who died this past year is a
very well-known dialect coach and in New
York and I had worked with him many many
moons ago and he broke it down like you
know broke all the sounds down so I had
no time was breaking all the sounds down
but it was a that process I think can
make it can stunt it sometimes you and
then you have to like find your rhythm
and the person that really helped me the
most in the end was a combination of
knowing this technique of what sounds I
needed to change but working with a
Polish woman I found this Polish woman
in my town that's an actor hmm and she
had been in America just the same amount
of town the time that Stella had so she
had enough of a mixture of an
Americanized polish accent and and I
worked with her and that that was the
easiest way to go about it cuz I could
listen to the rhythm and she's really
feminine so what's interesting too
because I walked in I was like oh my god
this woman's this woman and she had just
gone to this terrible divorce and she
was telling me about the dynamics of her
relationship and everything I was like
oh my god it's the same one so it was
perfect for me because it was just the
way she talked the way she
everything it was like oh I'm still in
this woman right we've taken I'm just
gonna take her and it really did help
and I would I had it whenever I was lost
I would you always go back to that did
you have as much time to prepare for the
character as you did for the accent
because it seems like it was a very
pretty difficult accent didn't seem like
an easy one it was hard and I didn't
have a lot of time and if it hadn't been
for this woman I don't know what I would
have done she really saved me and it was
partially it was not only the accent but
it was her bow she was very vulnerable
her Leno I wouldn't spent when I spent
time with her I just was like oh my god
it's a woman that's really who she is
and so I just paid attention to how she
talked and how she acted and the way she
moved just over what's your name what
was her name
it's been a couple of years since a Eva
but I can't remember a last name but
she's believe it or not she was
originally from Chicago so there's a
national look your honor the weight
should polish but she'd been in Chicago
and she just moved to actual Patrick
find ur ass there's a Nashville I was a
very artsy community there's a lot of
retirees from the business there a lot
of good writers and people in the
business that are retiring in Asheville
it's like the new place to go
so there's a lot of people in the
business that are there did you meet
with Debbie in terms of like talking
about her family experience or was it
just more toward the script or did she
take you through some of them since it's
loosely based on her opportunity did she
kind of take you to some of those
emotional places before seniors or was
it mostly just really based on what was
on page it's a mixture okay because it
was truthful and honest and it was her
history but as also she had some
creative licenses
far as a writer and and what the story
was and and though there were certain
things that she was dead set to stick to
that she did was very adamant and didn't
want to change there were other other
instances where she felt more there was
more flexibility yeah you know I think
it was important to her the whole
Holocaust thing that was or you know
that the fact that she had gone through
this experience of having to be kidding
them
that was that was pertinent for her and
important but I just remember too that I
was playing the role of her sister you
know and her family dynamic and in my
audition her sister was in the room so
her second
well well I don't she likes me how long
did it take to shoot the movie
altogether we only had 18 days 18 15
days yeah it was not an easy process and
the last night was hailed the last night
was a living hell she got a really good
taste of what an independent movies like
because she had really truly experienced
independence maybe I'm not for you but
it was true
but well at 1:30 in the morning they
wanted to call they wanted a break for a
second second meal and we were working
20-hour days yeah that was it we had
that day oh my they weren't cut off and
they have not done the scene of the
bedroom scene with me in Chas yet and I
was asking the DP and the crew was like
what we're gonna break for an hour all
done I can't I can't come back 2:30 in
the morning after eating okay there's no
way I can do this I said do you want to
eat this and believe me it's not our
idea we want to finish the movie retire
but I want to eat they would rather just
like do I forget the term but when
you're just
we're on the European way just grab
something and keep going but there's a
penalty there's a meal penalty involved
we're the movie production would have to
pay the penalty and so that's what it
was all about they don't want to pay the
penalty so I'm like how much money are
we talking about here let's we gotta
finish this we need to finish the movie
how much money were talking about and
because earlier that my chest he
predicted it wasn't even as it was all
happening I didn't even remember what he
had said until the next day I was like
oh it was that you know it's a 1:30 in
the one I was like yeah we're not we're
not breaking we're not breaking we got
it we have a choice here we go what do
you wanna do and everybody was like the
crew was so relieved and I think they
ended up forcing their their money
because they were just like okay good
time how can you work that hard and look
so good on the screen it's interesting
because when you work on a movie the
good news is you know what's not
eventually it's gonna be over so it's
like you get in this thing where you go
I have to just do it this long done so
everything is scheduled down to the
minute but it's also very enjoyable it's
not like it's an addiction what can I
say
total addiction a complete and utter
energy hard work but but everybody is
obviously addicted to it because they
keep
they keep doing it again and again and
again but you do sort of like get in
this idea of everything is down
precisely done like down to the fact
that you know you have X amount of time
to go to the bathroom and take a buy off
and then you have X amount of time to
put on your pajamas and get in the bed
you got to read five minutes and go to
sleep and you have X amount of time to
sleep when you get up and then you go
can you talk about anything that you're
gonna be doing what's next
I just moved out you're my bill months
ago with my boyfriend who actually plays
my boyfriend in the movie
I had a great companion up for the first
week on the film and then I lost it man
yeah I'm still yeah but it's been a
great thing he's a really great guy so
we won't just move it out here and we're
auditioning and trying to make good
connections a nice stir sing and write
music and Chris what can hard and trying
to make it you know the last you used
you know that the song yeah that's right
yeah she's an amazing boy no yeah she
auditioned for something the other day
people were like why aren't you
recording but yeah I had written on that
edition yes but that's not just thank
Andy with a lot of your prior roles
there were more headstrong women and and
with Stella she was more passive what
was it about her character that
attracted you to it
she was very well said I was a beautiful
story
tense intensely hard beautiful story and
I grew up in a very dysfunctional family
my mother was manic-depressive so it's
something I'm familiar with and I
thought the script was great and I'm it
was a really really good to get to work
with the child that was just icing on
the cake because at the time I was
talking to Debbie better I didn't know
and and then strangely freaky how we
ended up running into the casting
director at a play and I found Mattie
and they said what would like like a
rainy I was like oh okay and then I you
know was like no promises you either do
they like they choose you or not but
they want to see you and she was like
great and she did an amazing audition so
it's just like all these little things
just kind of fell into place so it was
you know it's a really good experience
that is really interesting how Mattie
and Natalie have two distinct ways of
dealing with the father and when Mattie
runs away Natalie says that she's not as
strong as her but do you feel that the
two sisters which one do you feel is the
stronger of the two
or are they both strong in different
ways I'd say they're different
I think Maddie is the most brave in a
way before she's feeling will stand up
to her father but it's also it takes
strength to be nice when you feel like
that you mean which which is in a lot of
ways what I think Natalie does so maybe
so she was manipulated too but her dad
made me feel special quite often so how
did you prepare for those scenes where
it was going to be a sort of a dark turn
and especially if you're doing what an
18 day shoot when you're pressed for
time where you go as an actor to prepare
like emotionally if you're gonna suppose
you have to walk on eggshells around
chassés character what do you do to kind
of prepare to go to that today is a
combination of having a create and
creative mind my mind so it's not
playing and I think it's a combination
of that a great imagination and like
experience technique but I always say a
cop mostly a combination of like I said
my mother was manic-depressive it's not
something I'm not I am very familiar
with this I grew up in a dysfunctional
codependent house so that's a lot to
draw from there and highly imagined
intense imagined mind
another feather in your cap that you had
recently was presenting or being at the
Golden Globes
yeah I read a story I guess before it
happened saying and you had said that
you were nervous about like tripping or
anything so now in retrospect how was
the experience and did you manage not to
trip I didn't trip thank goodness it was
the most is a wonderful experience of
whirlwind of a night basically meaning
every famous person in Hollywood is like
just gosh is it was a I'm so glad I was
able to do it someone told me it's like
hoarding cat it was like watching you
you've got these really powerful and
famous people and they don't know who
she is
yeah just you know a weak girl behind
him going trying to get them to go it
was funny watching cuz they would ignore
you quite often yeah lately
I would sort of like see you every once
in a while someone would actually
connect with you for the majority of
people everyone they were just a real
kite up there and they're so overwhelmed
that they just want to go there and I
have to try to and gosh it was the
hardest when there would be big groups
like the whole cast of Modern Family
came on it's just me that's a wrangle
and off David all right guys this way
every new was off I am very polite you
know kept and they always wanted to keep
going in the back yeah you'd be like
halfway through the show me what people
would pick up like okay but when go
right there
nope everyone wanted to go out that back
did you think a lot of that has to do
with the fact that they are
shell-shocked from just coming
definitely and I think so yeah and
they're happy and everybody drinks at
the Golden Globes
of course yes they have alcohol there
branding question for you if you were to
express how you want it the public or
the your demographic to see you how
would that be
as an actress or singer actress I'd like
to be taken seriously as my own person
and I'm very thankful for having my
mother but I think it also holds me to a
different standard than a lot of other
young actresses because I don't I have
to prove myself more than just any other
person because when I go into an
audition or if I'm if I book something
or if something happens because I've
been working hard word people will
always say oh she just got a cousin mom
so so let's say you proved yourself in
this phone cuz you really did thank you
what else would you we'd like to
continue getting work and continue
trying to do a good job and any
particular roles that you like the point
I'd love to do some kind of like musical
movie because I love to sing I've been
dancing since I was 2 and I obviously I
love to act so combining those three I
think would be a dream job
they don't make many movies like that
anymore
unfortunately I grew up watching The
Wizard of Oz I miss most movies what
about the stage you have any desire to
be on the stage certainly yeah a musical
theater in college and dance and acting
and she's gotten really close mmm so I
just you know I'd love to do
I just want to work and be taken
seriously as an actor so in keeping with
that ring watching your mom have a
successful career what have you learned
about what keeps a career afloat because
you've been around the business only
your whole life even if you haven't
always been doing stuff but you've seen
it my mom works really hard and a lot of
people think that being an actor and you
know having the boreal contract it must
be a very glamorous all the time but she
really she something expected you know
she's doing game by design right now and
she'll wake up at 5:00 and come home at
12:00 at night and she's exhausted but
she has to look great and she works
really hard and I think if you're
willing to work hard then you'll have a
good career and it's the same really
with any other career if you work hard
you do it well does took a lot of hard
work and preparation mm-hmm have you
guys done a lot a lot of publicity for
the film yet
listen it was up the Santa Barbara Film
Festival which I was able to go to so
you did some trust there but really this
is like the biggest day so far so but
you don't really tell you know you don't
really publicize that you're related I
mean when I read the invitation to come
here today and that was the first I knew
didn't know what when I was watching the
movie you know all that are you guys
gonna try to bring that about more when
you're I think she probably doesn't love
that at all but I don't want to go into
an audition and have them immediately
know like Oh anyway let's see what she
can do you know do I think it does it
does kind of like make some time
preconceived idea it's not fresh and I
think it's good it shouldn't have my
last name yeah and you remind me of
someone like an actress I get Jennifer
Anderson sometimes do you think I get
cherry Garson times I like to use an
analogy of playing golf one of the most
important aspects of getting the golf
balls is knowing the pathway and where
on the face of the club you're actually
let me hit the ball
it's that determines where the balls
gonna go so you did you've decided the
pathway that's right and she has now
made her face in Hollywood where exactly
do you see both of you going together I
don't think you can predict enough no
that's the thing but I'll tell you this
like I keep trying to predict things for
instance I thought that I wanted to live
in North Carolina cuz I'd want to get
old there guess what I don't know it's
like you can sit here and project
whatever you want to project but I mean
you can reject hopes maybe you know like
she's projecting the hope to work that
simple it's like everybody always say
what kind of care do you want to play I
think it's really hard
what do you say and I always felt like I
had to come up with something like God
what I'm gonna say
mark but I have what do you say it's not
really like for me it's interesting here
it's great scripts working with good
people it's really that simple and and
for her it's the simple point she wants
work anything give me a job that's it
that's the way it really it is and one
job leads to another job leads to
another job
hopefully I just way the game works if
we were to fantasize I could tell you my
fantasy I got loads of fantasies you got
one loads of fantasies have so many it's
ridiculous you are not that's what I
said in my mind will not bother yo God
because that to tell it shut up but you
know well constantly the imagination is
just going all over the place thank you
so much